- [Instructor] Now the last type of bond
I'm going to talk about is
known as the metallic bond,
which I think I know a little bit about
because I was the lead singer
of a metallic bond in high school.
I'll talk about that in future videos.
But let's just take one of
our metallic atoms here.
Iron is a good example.
Iron is maybe one of the
most referred to metals.
Let's say we have a bunch of iron atoms.
So Fe, Fe, Fe, Fe, hope you can read that.
These are all iron atoms.
And if they're just atoms by themselves
they're going to be neutral.
But when they are mushed together,
they will form a metallic bond.
Makes sense because they're metals.
And what's interesting
about metallic bonds,
I'll draw it down here, is
that metals like to share their electrons
with the other metals.
It kinda forms this sea of electrons.
So what it can look like is,
each of the irons lose an electron,
I'll draw it a little bit bigger.
So let's say this is Fe plus,
so it has a positive charge.
Fe plus has a positive charge.
Fe plus, these are all
iron ions, you can imagine.
Fe plus, and we're imagining
that they have this positive charge
because they've all
contributed an electron
to this sea of electrons.
So you have an electron here
which has a negative charge.
And electrons are not this big,
but this is just so that you can see it.
Electron here that has a negative charge.
And so you can imagine these
positive ions are attracted
to the sea of negativity, the
sea of negative electrons.
Another way to think about it is,
is that metals, when they
bond in metallic bonds,
they will have overlapping
valence electrons.
And those valence electrons are not fixed
to just one of the atoms,
they can move around.
And this is what gives metals
many of the characteristics
we associate with metals.
It conducts electricity
because these electrons can
move around quite easily.
It makes them malleable,
you can bend it easily.
You can imagine these iron ions
in this pudding, or this sea of electrons.
So you can bend it, it doesn't break.
Well if you were to take a
bar of a salt right over here,
if you were to try to
bend it, it's very rigid.
It is going to break.
So there we have it, the types of bonds.
It's important to realize
that you can view it
as something of a spectrum.
At one end, you have
things like ionic bonds
where one character swipes an electron
from another character and says,
"Hey, but now we're
attracted to each other,"
and you get something like salt.
Or you have covalent bonds
where we outright share electrons.
And then you have things
in between covalent bonds
and ionic bonds where the
sharing is not so equal
and you get polar covalent bonds.
And then another form,
I guess you could say,
of extreme sharing is the metallic bonds
where you just have this
communal sea of electrons.